[Music]
[Laughter]
all right and we are live
from the army army Hotel salute I love
podcast
lordsofgaming.net in the building at
East 2023 another one down gentlemen
successful trip for all a lot to discuss
before we get into that escape yeah
no we're not doing this we're not
putting the whole step into all that
stress so be a good rewards my course
call boss
doing pretty good uh
[Music]
download sovereign
doing well exhausted it was a definitely
one of the like funner trips it was fun
I mean I think that all of us really
really put 150 over into this one
because we all had weights way more
interviews than I think we ever had in
the past we have so much amazing stuff
coming for everybody so I think
now and of course the magic man the one
who gets all the great interviews known
as the hottest game before we know him
the magic launches her I'm doing great
Gus came off hold your own business
I thought that he was holding it out
we had like a mean Jean thing going on
oh yeah oh somebody looks big big Jade
I'm tired of coming off a long day of a
lot of great games a great weekend of
playing great game so I'm happy to hear
it no doubt in the rookie the Michael
Jordan it is his debut my man comes all
the way through from Indiana uh we doing
more Chris you net glad to be making my
day beautiful real Awards finally after
all the scribes of the
months
after winning so many times they
acknowledge me to come out sometimes
going back still gotta catch him to the
chair right here
that respect respect to the OG you don't
have my first big events such as packs
never got to experience something like
that and for you guys to bring me in
trivia's family it was an experience
that I'll never forget and of course we
have the man the myth the legend called
Deep City what the game went daily oh no
guys I see a bit of space again yeah
yeah you made sure he wore that shirt
serious but behave yourself sir but look
we got hockey Street in the building how
we doing brother I'm doing okay so glad
to get to be a part of this at some
point so finally we'll get I guess a
proper thing in one of the normal ones
oh yeah we're gonna give you the real
royalty but you know that's gonna do it
I don't know I mean from Indiana maybe
it's not Michael Jordan but uh oh
Celtics Legend Larry Bird
he is from Indiana
but look we got to get into it y'all put
another pack another one of the books I
guess we're gonna start off with just
like hey what are the standout one of
the things that kind of
and then
the normal uh one of the standouts is
definitely cakes that we saw already
experienced you know midnight
I'm about to lose a co-host super spicy
super spicy super spicy food
it was a good amount of games like it
was a when I do it it just looked
interesting to me was that hello
in the office and at first
you know so it's interesting but any
concept so then I actually played it I'm
like this game actually has something
like where they like yank them off the
stadium like yeah
[Music]
oh yes
and
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
actually today
down
[Music]
know
put in a modern automatic machine
classic Graphics
um and what was the other game the turbo
Overkill turbo yeah I remember that one
yeah yeah
Doom energy
um
yeah just it was just go go
actually let's see how far
is exciting but yeah
and again so much so that I think I
missed out yeah it was a lot it's like
last year I kind of felt like this song
pretty much
there was a lot of stuff that we just
either didn't have time to get to before
[Music]
your
all right well what stands out now is
more people that show up
um the way that they are booking now and
uh it's a little bit tighter but I'm not
going to give them out no matter I think
that a lot of devs or a lot of companies
I've got a lot of workers that can work
that hour work those shifts and don't
know anything about the product uh that
is uh you know there just to babysit uh
the stand or babysit the booth and
that's disappointing because a lot of
times we saw games that definitely
needed our attention we needed that
shine that light yeah if we're going to
talk about like Dead Island too when we
had an appointment to go see you guys it
was like a wasted time we could have
gave that time and space to somebody
else that was actually there to
participate I found that was really
unprofessional uh but the game looked
phenomenal so either you took your fan
base for granted and you wasted our time
or you just felt the game was going to
sell anyway you really didn't need the
the light on it but um the game looks
great looks phenomenal that was one of
my standouts there I like the Resurgence
of what I've seen in fighting games yeah
I've seen a ton of fighting games with
you know Tekken eight leading the charge
and followed by Street Fighter and a lot
of other games uh a call back to our
fighting games of old with uh Undisputed
yes no it has it's an indie game it has
a ton of Fighters that are there and
with a lot of indie games there are a
little rough edges they do need to work
on the impact of the punches but I felt
that they got the general movements and
behaviors of Fighters
um Knockouts
um beautiful
they worth it and it has a lot of
Promise so it's in beta right now and it
should be really good uh the toxic
Crusaders inside scrolling the beat em
ups oh coming back and so I would shoot
some rage we we see it with uh the Ninja
Turtles and this game looks to take it
even further I want to go back to how we
used to have aliens and and our Avengers
and expunishers
stuff like that so remember we had those
and they wasn't coming back it's a lot
of stuff on the showroom floor
everybody's out there I thought it was
uh impactful to see you know Jake about
you know uh just walking around and you
know Maddie plays
and everybody's starting to come back to
the window so I thought it was really
good yeah no doubt I'll jump into um it
was it was really cool to see you know I
think what I noticed is packed slowly
getting back it straight back and goes
like each year post pandemic you saw
like War hallways if the now we start to
see a little bit more feel so that at
100 but it's slowly coming back the
whole packs feel Nintendo runs back you
see that shout out to Xbox you get a
pop-up
[Music]
dad was so passionate about it I learned
more about it I thought it was going to
be one biome kind of like a desert mad
Maxi kind of vibe but then from the
finals then when he starts to do the
traversal and he's Silver Surfer saying
storm moving like Christmas you only
showing Chris how to do it we're doing
the gameplay it really blew me away so
they had the strongest one of course I
got a salute the home team dbo was in
full okay it was just so fun to see
people trying for the first time solved
tried it for the first time had so much
fun to see the community embrace them
and of course you got to sleep but
Laurie was in the building yeah
but Larry was in the building along the
dean you know what's the name of the
champion oh we don't want to know about
him I don't want to talk about it they
had a professional ringer Joe beat me
they called they set me up they're like
yeah
this dude is like
what's the Fighting Championship she's
the leadership he's like this is like
evil dude I'm like oh man I try I tried
to make it just like just don't get me
up out of there so fast you know what's
crazy that game wasn't enough
oh my God I don't want to talk about it
we got my faculties together you
deleting that footage they set me up but
all the jokes aside all jokes you know
the energy the scene like yeah everybody
crying around everybody
it just shows you how much that genre is
missing yeah and to see the energy those
are the shout outs probably like one
more I would say if you have the atlas
falling what was that one we played that
it was the four player it was the one
you ain't like
when they die like but it was that I
wanted to just like send everybody out
in the airline yeah it was void avoid
something it was a four player as well
yes it was full play and it was all
what's it called one crew void crew and
you gotta work together to put the ship
and go play stuff and it was it's funny
because
it's such a fun game you and me would
love that yeah because we would like
push people out the airline yeah it's
like serious Among Us
got [__] and stuff like that those of
us stand that was right there
what about you what was some of the
stuff for you uh I think that one of the
one of the things I really love to our
packs this year Not only was the amount
of people that were there the like the
reserve like the you know the rush of
every like all the vendors and
everything coming back
um I thought that was amazing
um I was kind of surprised by like how a
lot of the emails and stuff that we were
trying to get no one was replying back
and it was just yeah there was a lot
about a real weird unprofessionalism
we've never seen in the past but I think
that's because a lot of new blood is
coming in so they don't know how to
operate and do things so now they just
got kind of iron the stuff out so we
understand and you know hopefully
everything in the future will be a lot
easier
um but I would say that a lot of uh a
lot of games like capes yes was the
alien oh and the one
what was the name
the doctor something was good but was
down with the alien it was another alien
game that was right next to oh
um
um there was there was a handful of
games I was just surveys was in the
building yeah there was a lot of
tournaments this time around I mean like
War group two was out which I saw from
truffle finish that was really good
um I mean I felt like there was a really
like a lot of other amazing games a lot
of passion developers and taught to
someone like this is like the first time
they're even there almost a joint we
covered
um oh it was kind of like it was MMO us
three they it was really cool they had
to ask wayfinder wayfinder wayfinder I
mean that King's got so much potential
and from talking to you know the the
whole entire
um the whole Dev team like it sounds
like that is probably one the more
Community Driven games for MMO and
they're listening and they said that one
of their main components of their game
that they want to always make sure they
do is listen to the community and put in
what they want which is something that I
don't think most developers do
especially in the MMO genre of things
they just kind of like this is what we
want we know
we're gonna do what we want anyway so I
think that they have a lot of potential
there and I think things are really
really great I just said you were
talking all day I mean I think that
there was so many great things
um I mean I just I can't stop them I was
passing it over so yeah it's really good
man what about you
um what do you saying now is I know you
have some stuff to cut off site well one
of the things that stood out to me was
Dead Island 2 only because I thought
this was going to be awful you know
embracer has been known lately for
putting out seven seven out of ten seven
eight seven five embracers quality has
not been up to par uh Dead Island 2 has
been in development for over 10 years
now there'll be three development teams
at least as we know of we've been
through developing hell and back and
what we've played it's unfortunate there
wasn't a developer there and team there
and meet us there but what we played
Blue Max I think I was really surprised
the the mechanics the visuals the
weapons it's everything's there as it
should be and I was really impressive
and we got to play a small slice we
weren't able to ask the questions on how
you know what what representation of
this is the game but visually it's
fantastic the weapons are cool
it's interesting it's Unique that it's
fun and it's cool I went on site and I
met with the CEO of digital Sun they're
the developers uh Spain that did
moonlighter and Lobos they're working
yeah they're working with Riot games on
a action adventure
pixel art game that is uh coming out on
April 18th called the Mage Seeker A
League of Legends Story the next place
from League of Legends Universe
fantastic game I absolutely love it and
uh you had an idea one of your besties
it was probably my favorite game of the
show but I have a huge moonlighter fan
moonlighter with some Game Pass forever
that was a fantastic indie game you know
um and we all love that yeah this is
without the shop mechanics but it's a 15
hour story and a riot let them go nuts
and do a lot of really cool stuff to the
store they gave me some stuff I don't
really want to spoil for anyone but uh
the story is really good
yeah there's the NBA in the back of the
door and a lord of the dark was really
cool I wouldn't I think most people who
listen to ILP are gonna be probably more
Dreamcast Centric and you're gonna be
thinking about alone in the dark as a
dream but this is alone in the dark as a
a 3eo MS-DOS game and that's from them
it's reading of that Universe completely
detached from what was on the Wii and
what was on the Dreamcast visually I
mean it's very close to what has been
going on with Resident Evil it doesn't
look like a remake of a costume they're
using elements of that Universe it's a
whole new game it's a whole new
experience but it has nothing to do with
it can I can I say something I want to
say that when they when they when we
spoke to the guys
when we when we spoke to the Developers
for alone in the dark
um I will say that the game looked
amazing yeah and they did not want to
watch the video anything because they
don't want to spoil anything for anybody
and I think that we only got 30 minutes
left
wrap it up but anyway there was there
was a lot of really really cool elements
and I will say that that's something
definitely everybody should keep an eye
out for it was so good uh brick NDA
maybe not breaking NBA we played the
prologue demo and you're gonna have a
chance to play that soon it's gonna go
out in the general public pretty soon we
did not play the full game or part of
the game we played the pro log exclusive
uh Republic and of course uh the last
thing we'll talk about Nina the
Hollywood from Yacht Club memes love
Yacht Club games you can play travel
night they're doing they describe it as
a Game Boy Color game I don't think
that's fair because it looks something
more akin to like what you would see
from the Super Nintendo and the visuals
are more than anything you would expect
from the Game Boy Color game uh and it's
got fun games and mean and holler is so
cool with the character in the universe
and there's lots of Castlevania and I
just love everything
hit the ground running camera photo apps
you're doing it all what about you but
when you're staying now again was a huge
experience and like I said something
I'll never forget and I'll mentioned
demio Lord sovereign's first foray into
it another me and cause and feeding
playing all the time not just demio in
general but the same cosplay shut up oh
yeah they did that they did that
especially coming in dressed up as
klepto today yes with all that that
definitely can't be yeah that's not easy
if y'all see the crypto character y'all
understand that you mentioned Atlas fall
on the game that I'm not in tune to the
client normally played and you mentioned
the sand surfing maybe we'll jump up in
the air grapple pull yourself closer you
got this sight you can throw around
absolutely amazing looks phenomenal
um altarian shift like attic mentioned
Harps back to the old school jrpgs so I
mean you know old school Final Fantasy
old school Suite then my baby oh yeah if
you're into that you'll love alterium
ship I actually got to play a little bit
more than what the video was showing
because I played twice there's fishing
there's a whole bunch of stuff that's
extra included okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
I was like yes please
that was the only thing but apparently
you did it I did get there the camera
cut off I did get to strangle me some
more
now Andy Circus is a mastermind when it
comes to ordering you're a big Lord of
the Rings fan you live in your circus
you look calm this is as close as you
can get I believe without making any
surface to the voice actually there we
go
I did get to see a little bit of the
secondary which we didn't get on video
right the guy came back we talked a
little bit early
though Early Access I will say the
camera work yeah he needs some work when
you're traversing climbing up Cliffs you
have to jump backwards instead it's kind
of hard to see but he showed me the dark
territory of Mordor going into the
buildings dark grimy it fits absolutely
what you think border would look like
nice phenomenal game and I think it will
be bigger than a 7g
Gumball
[Music]
above
to hit the floor yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
looks very nice and they had a whole
Entourage there that whole year they had
old ring yeah but around the corner was
the true champ oh oh I know and the true
champ is with the story now in Russell's
story is a turn-based wrestling game and
it plays like Final Fantasy with a huge
story and it is probably the most unique
take on a wrestling game that I've ever
seen I'm in it
[Music]
um and this is where this ends oh
findings
[Applause]
and I quote
outside
so that's essentially
[Music]
thank you
yeah it was uh quite an interesting uh
Friday this whole week has been crazy
right fall previews we have GDC lots of
cool stuff coming out of there
especially with Ninja Theory and then
this whole big disclosure that came up
uh essentially you know they fixed
Sony's numbers and said okay it looks
like this would be a problem Microsoft
could take it away it would cause
Financial harm and it would be
beneficial to Microsoft and Microsoft
said well no you took numbers that are
wrong they were years out versus year to
year and they they took Microsoft's
analysis and said you're right there is
no Financial benefit in fact you would
have losses if you took this game away
from the Sony so there's just no SLC
here uh there's no point in calling the
console an issue on top of that they put
the game on Nintendo right they took
away Sony's big calling saying Nintendo
is not a competitor no putting it on the
Nintendo switch forget we're putting on
the Xbox we'll put it on the Nintendo
switch so they've taken all the cards
away from Sony but basically eliminated
that whole problem and now back to cloud
is the only thing right as we can see a
live provider in the world and saying
here's your 10-year deal here's your
10-year deal you get a 10 year deals
and they're essentially going to end
that whole thing this thing is close to
finishing up at this point do you think
do you think this was one of the major
tipping points to kind of just push it
through
the one you know Oddity is or the one
potential wildcard right right the FTC
is the case I don't know if you know
this is uh the gamer's lawsuit was also
awesome
and that was based on everything the FTC
had said so the FTC has no case uh so if
it does go to federal court it's going
to get tossed I don't think it's gonna
go there though I think efcc is going to
come to the table after all this from
the CMA and the UK and EBC they're going
to try to make a deal before they can
see finishes there uh so they're gonna
come to try and do the wall uh but the
EC had already tossed up it already
tossed their stuff out it was just cloud
and the CMA doing the same thing it's
pretty much about at this point but yeah
the CMA is saying that the consulate
part is gone that was where they wanted
the investiture of Call of Duty that's
now
pretty close to Green I think the CMA
goes first FTC next you see last two
just finishes
[Music]
you mentioned the sand surfing they will
jump up in the air grapple pull yourself
closer you got the sights you can throw
around
absolutely amazing it looks phenomenal
um alterium shift like attic mentioned
Harps back to the old school jrpgs so I
mean you know old school Final Fantasy
old school Suite then my baby oh yeah if
you're into that you'll love alterium
shift I actually got to play a little
bit more than what the video will show
because I played twice there's fishing
there's a whole bunch of stuff that's
extra included okay you also paid
oh yeah
[Laughter]
I was like yes
[Music]
thank you
now Andy Circus is a mastermind when it
comes to ordering your big Lord of the
Rings fan you live in your circus you
look calm this is as close as you can
get I believe without making any surface
to the voice actually
I did get to see a little bit of the
secondary which we didn't get on video
right the guy came back we talked a
little bit
early access I will say the camera work
yeah it needs some work when you're
traversing climbing up Cliffs you have
to jump backwards instead it's kind of
hard to see but he showed me the dark
territory of Mordor going into the
buildings dark grimy it fits absolutely
what you think border would look like
nice phenomenal game and I think it will
be bigger than a 7g
what's the bet what's the best
gumbo
[Music]
okay
excuse me
[Laughter]
[Music]
looks very nice and they had a whole
Entourage
they had old ring yeah but around the
corner was the true champ oh oh I know
and the true chair is the story now in
Russell's story is a turn-based school
wrestling game and it plays like Final
Fantasy with a huge story and it is
probably the most unique take on a
wrestling game that I've ever seen I
mean
[Music]
um and this is where this ends rest
request looks like a 16-bit games bro
this looks like a 32-bit you know I feel
that yeah
all I would say is um you know there's a
lot of contenders for this world yeah
yeah and as we listen to that new uh
lost gaming down the interview that we
have with uh my men from Mega cat
Studios he actually put his belt on he
said there's a lot of droids out here
trying to act like they are the jrpg
wrestling story champion and he said I
challenge these upper covers he
literally said it on interview I was
like oh I'm taking shots of the game on
the floor I was like this dude yeah he
was right down he was right he said yeah
because he's overdos we did it first
yeah
and he said listen down there I'm gonna
tell you if we the real chair and he had
the belt so guess what I'm saying
findings
[Applause]
do it too
our good friend Tom Warren shout out
Warren shout diverse
and I quote
you're killing me here
you gotta go back hit the bag
you came regular inside myself
[Music]
yeah it was uh quite an interesting
Friday this whole week has been crazy
right four previews GDC lots of cool
stuff coming out of there especially
with Ninja Theory and then this whole
big disclosure that came up uh
essentially you know they fixed Sony's
numbers and said okay it looks like this
would be a problem Microsoft could take
it away it will cause Financial harm and
it would be beneficial to Microsoft and
Microsoft said well no you took numbers
that are wrong they were years out
versus year to year and they they took
Microsoft's analysis and said you're
right there is no Financial benefit in
fact you would have losses if you took
this game away from the Sony so there's
just no SLC here there's no point in
calling the console an issue on top of
that they put the game on Nintendo right
they took away so many big points saying
Nintendo is not a competitor for us no
putting it on the Nintendo switch forget
we're putting on the Xbox we'll put it
on the Nintendo switch so they've taken
all the cards away from facility which
basically eliminated that whole problem
and now back to cloud is the only thing
right as we can see there's a lot of
provider in the world and saying here's
your 10-year deal here's your 10-year
deal
and they're essentially going to end
that whole thing this thing is close to
finishing up
do you think this was one of the major
tipping points to kind of just push it
through
the one you know Oddity of those are the
one potential wildcard right right the
FTC is the case I don't know if you know
this is uh the gamer's lawsuit was also
awesome
and that was based on everything the FCC
had said so the FTC has no case so if it
does go to federal court it's gonna get
tossed I don't think it's gonna go there
though I think efcc is going to come to
the table after all this from the CMA in
the UK and EBC they're going to try to
make a deal before
uh so they're gonna come Detroit but the
EC had already tossed out so it already
tops their stuff title with just cloud
and the CMA doing the same thing it's
pretty much about at this point but yeah
the CMA is saying that the controlling
part is gone that was where they wanted
the investiture of Call of Duty that's
now
pretty close to the green I think the
CMA goes first FTC next you see last two
just finishes
[Music]
I like but someone finally pointed out
it's like look like I get what you say
it over here so it's like would you know
it's like okay
hey Japan you've got this you know 98
market share Sony and you don't do
anything to regulate them what's going
on and they're now looking into Sony
it's another big huge thing that's
happened
but the thing about it is
[Music]
um
release the puzzle
but no that was it to me it's just like
finally it feels like please
[Music]
I don't know what you're talking about
what's more annoying is the Fanboys of
that platform act like they don't do the
same thing it's it's all but it's
different no if anything I would say
before you buy the company and you and
you back that ecosystem you back that
complete man on business bro
so this is where snitching goes wrong
look at you
none of the stuff that you said was real
and they looking at you now you've been
doing this bad practices uh where's my
final fantasy 7. I refuse to play it on
the PlayStation because I don't care I
want it on my Xbox we said it was coming
where's that it's a third-party game
where it's at if you're doing shaving on
the hand and stuff then let me know that
I'm never gonna get come on save it no
no you ghosting me you got my money you
ghosting me
I want my final fantasy it looks like
you're gonna have to get that up
we had the time now where they're
looking at what you're doing
and what I like I like most
all these fake dudes that y'all was
talking about oh this deal might not
close I'm 50 50. all of a sudden y'all
are 100 that way
making
[Music]
I mean but I've always said you know in
my mind it never it gave the consumer
choice I looked at from the consumer
standpoint and then long term as long as
they're not pulling it away from foreign
[Music]
they're trying
the thing I want to talk about though
just honestly
oh yeah
Paul well we'll see and it feels that
way the thing that I want to seek to me
which is the bigger picture for
Microsoft is if this goes right let's
say April whatever and May June now
you're looking at a year where starfish
right you're looking at it here with
that Call of Duty and maybe all of
activism religious titles
right that's the ultimately what this is
about entering game but they're not
going to pull it away from other
platforms but you haven't enjoy service
compelling point we're talking about
Lasik marketing clouds you're allowing
these other Cloud providers to also
happen so that to me that was the legit
argument because I felt Azure was strong
and if they had that that to me really
hurts other new people in the space you
not competing with game pass at that
time so you put that in there they take
I guess those consensions are
essentially help the EU try to get on
board and now we get through this and I
just think if it goes to me
in Game Pass attention this yeah yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
just be here in here I know I know
you've been on the other side of this so
it'll be fair oh okay I never know I
always felt that again so I apologize
okay and I would never you know pull the
problems for any company but full
disclaimer uh after uh Acquisitions our
acquisition was acquired I did purchase
activities
smart man
um and you were listening off some
things that they were going to come to
me and ask them one of the things I
think about it is how far could they go
back in terms of what they're going to
put in game at you know um
[Music]
how far back are they going to go I I
think within a week they could go as far
back as uh Xbox One Xbox 360. I don't
know how much further back they could go
um
right and also also you know playing
playing double second again I think that
they're gonna have a major rebranding
and I think that there will no longer be
an Xbox app and a Game Pass App I think
there will be one app where purpose was
made inside of that app and that app
will be available in web browser on
pretty much everything last weekend a
little bit that happens this year next
year three years I think within the
first week of taking control I think all
the live Subs become Gamecast Subs
overnight
no I don't think so wow I don't think so
what do we feel about community so uh
with when it comes to like the wow like
the whole entire side of that and
blizzard I mean I can see taking
blizzard but making
forcing a subscription on top of a
subscription
it'll have to happen
unfortunately when it comes to Warcraft
it's its own entity and it's the same
thing like if I was having you know if I
wanted to play games like Game Pass and
then I want to still play Warcraft I'm
gonna have to have two subs anyway and
that's what I have right now I have my
game pass and I also have my lab on a
date but if they emerge if they emerge I
can I can see them restricting access no
no because they have that now no no no
no way because that's how they're going
to inflate their heat passengers they're
going to absorb those 5 million wild
subs and the Starcraft Subs whatever all
it's other subs if lizard has and
they're going to convert this in a game
pass and you're gonna say whatever
you're paying now we're gonna convert
that new game pass which costs more than
a wow sub we're going to give that to
you and absorb you in but when you're a
subscription expires your your game pass
sub is going to run out you have to
renew the regular price
I really don't think that that would be
the case because I don't sorry I'm sorry
I think that if they end up doing that
it's gonna be really really um really
really hurtful to the whole entire world
Community because would you stop at the
beginning
no I would stop playing because the the
cost should be a lot more well we just
considering
from Microsoft the cost is going to be a
lot more they did this experiment before
with gold right they increase the price
and there was a massive backlash I don't
think they would force it I think
they're going to put it in game it'll be
part again maybe they would maybe they
would end up putting in Game Pass and
giving people the options or the other
exactly that's the whole difference what
about the big requests
what happened
see first of all time I will tell you
this Battlement launcher is trash they
just get rid of Battlement launchers
because the communication options and
stuff in there I could see them removing
it but I do not think that they are
going to
um take away the option
for Wow subscribers to end up having to
be courses because they are not gonna do
it
not but we'll see look this is a good
question to see the aftermath if you
don't want that happen but we got to get
those questions good coaching time for
Christmas it's news Pro you know I can
just break it looks like it's losing in
the favor of Microsoft man I don't
really have a lot to say I'm glad it'll
finally be over because I watched and
support so many different podcasts and
hearing the same games
over and over again and every podcast
but I will say my guess is what Gary
says for 9.99 a month
a little gay fast baby
but uh
you know what I'm just gonna talk about
the World of Warcraft I honestly believe
that they're going to make it better a
little bit more streamlined stuff like
that and the way that you get in you
will I don't think you're gonna walk
away from someone I think that's
hyperbole I think that it's something
that a fit attack is interesting if they
do this then I would definitely won't
work I don't think so I think at this
time because this is why okay
[Music]
they're [__] good this year right and
the weather actually uh is just a
convenience
shout out to no amdb it just it just
made us finally where are we staying
yeah
great great room great service
you guys know how we are man we didn't
like what we tell you but we generally
like the service and we like the
location and it's right across the
street I can literally look out for a
window and see the front door that I'm
gonna be annoyed that I have to go I
have a premium room service
your breakfast your breakfast
thoughts
like I said before I'm Bill Collins at
this patch that I will live for a
lifetime and a big shout out to Jean
especially allowing me to have a place
to stay dry I can experience this with
all these great people and like I said
I'll cherish this memories you work hard
[Music]
yeah
you know repop it from coming back
so the conversation about what that
looks like but I'm excited I'm excited
With Coupons
please pause
[Laughter]
[Music]
uh we got a new uh fighter a member
that's going to be playing all the
fighting games
and I love the fact that AJ has now
embraced racism
and I see potential energy
that's right that's how it goes from
ReDiscover the fight but um
last year when you saying it was uh it
was a little formula that he did and we
was passing that formula on to a lot of
people uh Boston sometimes that's a
little bit inconvenient uh with the
traffic that's in Boston and the times
that we have to leave and like if I
forgot my badge like I did that last
time I had to go all the way back
so this time we was just right across
the street and the Omni is probably the
best hotel for you to stand I mean it's
not probably it is the best hotel so
um they gave us this wonderful space the
only supposed to actually do a show
for you guys and they did it with no
problem uh so I feel like if you don't
say any places you stay at the Omni
Hotel and uh where the staff is even
Immaculate from the service is
incredible and they have breakfast oh
god oh yes yes chef cheers I I I went
against the Green today and I got Dunkin
Donuts I'll never do that again I'm
sorry on me yeah I definitely catch up
today but um you know I had a great time
especially the same friends with family
yeah they're getting a chance to have
hard geek on the show bags a lot you
know um I told them that before and I
was like yeah I just wanted him there
you know because if you really mean a
lot to us a fantastic person and I think
more people should actually uh you know
look to you for deposit because
yeah
a magic genius here longness minus PD is
here
um if y'all haven't set up the pizza
Channel please what's up dude
[Applause]
I don't know
it's great to see it's starting to open
back up I can't imagine what E3 is going
to be like I hope it'll be crazy yeah
right we'll I'll be catching up down
there and yeah this uh this year will be
interesting as far as Sony's coming out
right before and I know they're gonna
bring a whole bunch of stuff now and
then hopefully Microsoft responds we'll
see how that goes but yeah it's good to
see that this game's coming up it's just
good stuff coming up and then yeah this
week has been it's a fun one
for certain fans for certain fans moving
on so for some people might be in their
feelings
oh damn messy anyway real quick too oh
shots
that Mr Maddie plays
oh
[Music]
fighting games
expected with RTS strategy game farming
games
um for almost four years the day after I
just met you guys out of taxes back here
the magic man oh shout out yeah shout
out Lord Dunkey animal well I had no
ducky pulled up video game Donkey the
legend yeah yeah and finally my man my
Ace on one two another one in the books
number one oh final doing something oh
I wanna go to sleep
it's just been intense and it's exciting
I love spending time with you guys and
we're trying to say just happy another
one in the books and can't wait for
another one next year so no doubt shout
out to a seller shout out to a seller
with the greatest but most is yes
the Lord's had to give y'all something
you know again from past what we do you
know we go into the shows we go to these
conventions
it's always in Kansas and it gets real
we're real friends yeah everybody loves
each other and I love the community the
community gives back and we have to give
y'all something and I mean just to show
y'all The Experience packages
please check them out make this state
very pleasant like they've been exceeded
a little respect and they showed
tremendous privacy shout out to the
entire team and if you oh shout out to
hip hop game up yeah
for me in the building so many people oh
shout out to my man Mr K step got the
shout out from Greg Miller so many
people so much anybody that I didn't
forget anybody that said hello every one
of us we send our love back yeah
done dude